the universe was the Milky Way galaxy it
was Preposterous to think about
something beyond our galaxy because that
would mean beyond our universe nowadays
ironically we talk about things beyond
our universe and we'll probably get into
some of that when we discuss the
Multiverse in a little bit but the
universe was found to be much larger
than the Milky Way galaxy in fact there
were galaxies outside the Milky Way
galaxy that we observed the most famous
one being the Andromeda nebula which is
now call the a great spiral galaxy
Andromeda galaxy it's actually the
farthest thing Jordan that you can see
with the human eye if you look up on a
clear night you can see a smudge and
I'll show you the next time you're in
San Diego but I will show you as clear
smudge through my telescope and you can
see it with your naked eye as well that
smudge is particles of light photons
coming from a Galaxy and those photons
set out on their journey to your eye
when there were hominids walking around
on the Serengeti Plains of Africa the
light that reaches us today is 3 million
years old It's been traveling for three
million years since Lucy was extant so
that light from that Galaxy is not being
redshifted or blue shifted tremendously
but if you look at every other Galaxy
and we can see about a hundred billion
galaxies and each one has at least 100
billion stars and each one of those
Stars probably has tens or thousands of
minor bodies asteroids planets around
them the numbers are truly astronomical